hacer que europa vuelva a moverse y
mantener sus fronteras abiertas de forma
segura así fue como la presidenta de la
comisión europea ursula von der leyen
presentó los puntos positivos del
llamado pasaporte vacunas o como se
conoce oficialmente el certificado verde
digital edge shows stage muestra o
indica si la persona ha sido vacunada o
una prueba negativa reciente o se ha
recuperado de kobe 19 y por lo tanto de
anticuerpos por fábrica versión
ofertadas antiguo en segundo lugar este
certificado garantizará que los
resultados o lo que muestre los datos el
conjunto mínimo de datos se reconozcan
mutuamente en todos los estados miembros
y el pase en sí sería distribuido por
las autoridades nacionales o los
servicios de salud contendría
información personal básica en inglés y
en el idioma del país de misión así como
un código qr el documento debería ser
gratuito y la unión europea debería
brindar apoyo a los estados miembros
para desarrollar e implementar esta
tecnología el paso digital ha sido
aplaudido por algunos como una forma de
hacer que el turismo vuelva a funcionar
este verano pero también ha planteado
cuestiones éticas y logísticas con
respecto a la protección de datos y la
igualdad de acceso a los viajes sin
embargo la unión europea se apresuró a
recordar a los europeos que su libertad
fundamental de movimiento entre los
estados miembros no estaba amenazada el
pase digital simplemente facilitaría los
viajes erradicando la necesidad de
protocolos o pruebas de cuarentena todas
las vacunas aprobadas por la agencia
europea de medicamentos estarían
autorizadas para el certificado de hecho
la presidenta de la comisión europa
subrayó que con una tercera ola de kobe
de la mira la vacunación generalizada es
la mejor estrategia